a battle over making drug prices more
transparent for consumers is escalating
between the federal government and the
pharmaceutical industry health officials
want drug ads that appear on TV to
include the list price of the
medications the new proposal would apply
to all brand-name drugs covered by
Medicare and Medicaid which is most
prescription medicines chip Reid is
outside the Department of Health and
Human Services in Washington with what
this could mean for patients chip good
morning
well good morning for millions of
Americans who pay for their prescription
drugs mostly out of pocket the toughest
pill to swallow is the cost so now the
Trump administration is taking a bold
move they want to require drug companies
to put the prices of their drugs right
on the TV screen little Elijah just 5
needs a drug with a big price tag nearly
$300,000 a year living with a
life-threatening condition Elijah was
just three when he landed in the
hospital he was screaming mommy why am I
here mommy please take me home after his
family couldn't and their insurance
company wouldn't cover the cost of a key
drug people are cutting their pills in
half they are going without food they're
being hospitalized and they're even
dying because they can't afford the
prescription drugs that happened to us
and it's happening all over the country
president Trump has said drug companies
are getting away with murder one of my
greatest priorities is to reduce the
price of prescription drugs I've always
looked forward to what's next
now the Trump administration wants to
add to these ads forcing drug makers to
put right on the screen the price
patients could pay for a 30-day supply
but drug companies have another idea
we're concerned that if you just have
the list price in isolation in the ad it
may deter patients from seeking needed
care instead offering to point patients
to web sites listing each drugs price
estimated out-of-pocket costs and any
available discounts the industry is
meeting surprise resistance from
president Trump's Health and Human
Services Secretary Alexei czar a former
drug company executive but placing
information on a website is not the same
as putting it right in an ad we think
our approaches
a better way better for consumers yes do
you think you're going to be able to
convince secretary a czar of that and
more importantly president Trump I hope
so
but already families like Elijah's say
it's not enough listing the drug price
and direct-to-consumer advertising is
not going to lower our prices
Elijah's mother was so frustrated over
the cost of his drugs that she moved her
family of four here to Washington to
advocate for affordable drugs and she
just got some good news her drug company
her insurance company is going to pick
up the cost of a drug for Elijah that
would have cost a quarter million
dollars a year out of pocket Nora all
right thank you of that lobbying has
paid off but the question is why are
they fighting the transparency I mean
everything I've learned about my
reporting is the essentially middle men
and middle women that are in between
what the cost of a drug is and then by
the time it gets to you from your doctor
and your pharmacy through the pharmacy
benefit managers there's a lot of middle
people in between there so why shouldn't
drug carmakers yeah yeah